>> Tucker: IN RECENT
APPEARANCE ON AUSTRALIA
TELEVISION PINK HAIRED
DESCRIBE DEAN CARSON SAID
THAT PARENTS SHOULD ASK
BABIES FOR THEIR CONSENT
BEFORE CHANGING THEIR
DIAPERS.
THE INTENT IS TO FOSTER A
CULTURE OF CONSENT FOR
BABIES WHO WOULD BE, OF
COURSE, IN DEEP TROUBLE IF
THEY ACTUALLY NEEDED TO
SUPPLY CONSENT FOR ANYTHING.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY CRAZY BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT WON'T
HAPPEN OR BECOME THE LAW IN
THIS COUNTRY AND SO TO CHECK
ON WHAT THE FUTURE IS GOING
TO LOOK LIKE WE BRING OUR
LIBERAL SHERPA CATHY AREU TO
JOIN US.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: SO CONSENT FOR
DIAPER CHANGING FOR BABIES.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: LEAVING THIS OFF
WHETHER IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
IT RAISES THE OBVIOUS
TACTICAL QUESTION.
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: HOW WOULD A BABY
GIVE CONSENT?
>> WELL, THE IDEA ISN'T
EXACTLY THE BABY IS NOT
GOING TO SAY YES OR NO BUT
SAYING GIVE THE BABY A FEW
MOMENTS.
TALK TO THE BABY SAY IS IT
OKAY I'M GOING TO CHANGE
YOUR NAPPY SHE IS AUSTRALIAN
THAT'S HOW THEY SAY DIAPERS.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULDN'T SAY
THAT TO AN AMERICAN BABY.
>> I DON'T THINK AN AMERICAN
BABY WOULD UNDERSTAND.
ACTUALLY JUST TEACHING
CONSENT WHAT CONSENT IS
TEACHING BODY AUTONOMY.
TEACHING I'M NOT GOING TO
TOUCH YOUR BODY IF YOU DON'T
WANT ME TO.
IT'S JUST LIKE TALKING TO A
BABY ABOUT ANYTHING.
MOMMY LOVES YOU.
DADDY LOVES YOU.
SO PEOPLE TALK TO BABIES ALL
THE TIME SO WHY WOULDN'T THE
CONCEPT OF TALKING TO A BABY
WHILE DOING SOMETHING SO
SERIOUS AS, YOU KNOW,
CHANGING A DIAPER BE SO
RIDICULOUS?
>> Tucker: BECAUSE YOU
TYPICALLY DON'T EXPECT A
BABY TO RESPOND IN A WAY
THAT CAN YOU UNDERSTAND.
AGAIN, HOW DO YOU KNOW WHAT
CONSENT LOOKS LIKE?
LET'S JUST DO A LITTLE ROLE
PLAY GOING WE COULD.
>> ROLE PLAYING, I'M THE
BABY.
AND YOU ARE CHANGING MY
DIAPER.
>> Tucker: I'M GOING TO MAKE
THIS CHANGE.
>> UM-HUH.
>> Tucker: AND YOU, HOW DO
YOU EXPRESS YOUR CONSENT OR
LACK OF CORN SENT FOR THAT?
>> WELL, IF I START CRYING,
SOMETHING'S WRONGS, SO YOU
PROBABLY DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING AT THAT MOMENT
BECAUSE YOU WOULDN'T WANT TO
MAKE DIAPER CHANGING
SOMETHING THAT GOES ALONG
WITH CRYING.
YOU WOULD PROBABLY WANT ME
TO BE IN A HEALTHY STATE OF
MIND SO THAT IN THE FUTURE
WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE
PRIVATE THINGS, I HAVE BEEN
I WILL BE A WELL-ADJUSTED
ADULT.
>> Tucker: MAYBE THE CHILD'S
CRYING BECAUSE HIS DIAPER IS
DIRTY.
>> RIGHT.
OBVIOUSLY.
YEAH.
SO, I MEAN, THE PARENT WOULD
HAVE TO BE THE BEST JUDGE OF
THAT.
BUT, I GUESS HE WOULD MAKE
ME CRY IF YOU ASKED ME IF I
WANTED YOU TO, AND THEN I
STARTED CRYING, MAYBE YOU
SHOULD GET A HINT, TAKE THE
HINT.
>> Tucker: WOULD IT BE LIKE
AN EYE GESTURE?
YOU ARE A MOM.
DO YOUR KIDS CAN YOU READ
THEIR FACIAL EXPRESSIONS AND
KNOW THAT WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING?
>> SUPER HEALTHY.
BABY EXPERT SAID 0 TO 2 ARE
THE TRUST YEARS.
DURING THE TRUST YEARS YOU
WANT THE BABY TO TRUST YOU.
SO THERE IS NOTHING WRONG
WITH TALKING TO A BABY AND
THOSE SITUATIONS JUST
TEACHING A BABY HOW TO
TRUST.
SO, THIS IS A MOMENT WHERE
YOU ARE TEACHING A BABY TO
TRUST YOU.
SO I DON'T THINK THE BABY IS
EXPECTED TO NECESSARILY GIVE
CONSENT.
YOU ARE JUST TEACHING THE
BABY TO TRUST YOU.
YOU ARE ASKING THE BABY FOR
BODILY -- YOU ARE ASKING THE
BABY TO EXPRESS BODILY
AUTONOMY.
THAT'S THE BIG POINT HERE.
>> Tucker: BABIES ARE NOT
SUPER GREAT AT UNDERSTANDING
ENGLISH.
MAYBE OTHER BABIES ARE MORE
INTELLIGENT THAN MINE WERE.
WHAT IF THE CHILD KEEPS
SAYING NO LIKE OVER A PERIOD
OF WEEKS AND YOU KEEP GOING
IN THERE AND REALLY LIKE TO
CHANGES THE DIAPER BUT THE
CHILD REFUSES TO GIVE ME
CONSENT AT SOME POINT IT
BECOMES NEGLECT AND ALSO
NSAY.
>> CONCEPT OF TEACHING
CONSENT.
TALKING ABOUT IT DURING THAT
MOMENT SO MANY PARENTS DO
NOT DISCUSS IT AND THEY --
THE BABIES GROW UP AND THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE THEY'RE NOT
EVEN USED TO TALKING ABOUT
THOSE THINGS.
TEACHING TRUST, IT'S TRUST
ISSUE.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T REALLY
DISCUSS ANYTHING WITH A
BABY.
>> YOU DISCUSS EVERYTHING
WITH A BABY.
I'M GOING TO PUT THIS LOTION
ON YOUR ARM.
YOU TALK ABOUT EVERYTHING.
I'M GOING TO DRESS YOU.
PARENTS TALK TO BABIES ALL
DAY LONG.
I'M MAKING DINNER FOR YOU.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT THE
POLIO VACCINE.
>> YEAH GET A VACCINE.
YES PEOPLE HAVE TO GIVE
CONSENT.
YOU CAN'T GIVE ORGANS IF YOU
DON'T GIVE CONSENT.
EVEN DEAD PEOPLE CAN MAKE
DECISIONS WHY CAN'T BABIES?
>> Tucker: MAKE DECISIONS.
>> YOU HAVE TO GIVE CONSENT
TO HAVE THE ORGANS TAKEN
AFTER YOU DIE YOU CAN GIVE
CONSENT FROM A BABY YEAR TO
YOUR DEATH?
PEOPLE SHOULD ALWAYS GIVE
CONSENT IF THEIR BODY IS
GOING TO BE TOUCHED.
>> Tucker: SO, RIGHT, IF THE
CHILD SAYS NO, I DON'T WANT
THE BABY INDICATES BY CRYING
OR ROLLING HIS EYES I DON'T
WANT A POLIO RACK SEEN THEN
YOU JUST DON'T GIVE THEM A
POLIO VACCINE THEN?
>> I THINK IT'S THE IDEA OF
DISCUSSING IT WITH THE BABY.
THE CONSENT, I DON'T THINK,
IS NECESSARILY OUT ISSUE.
IT'S THE IDEA.
>> Tucker: OH.
>> YOU ARE DEVELOPING TRUST.
>> Tucker: EVEN IF THE BABY
SELLS NO, NO DOESN'T REALLY
MEAN NO.
>> THE BABY CAN'T TALK
DURING THE DIAPER YEARS.
>> Tucker: BABY'S NO DOESN'T
MEAN NO.
I TOTALLY GET THAT WHERE IS
THE OBEDIENCE.
CHILD LEARNS TO OBEY WHAT
YOU SAY.
GIVE AND TAKE COLLOQUY WITH
A
MUTE PERSON.
>> THIS IS DIVERSIFICATION
TALKING WITH THE BABY.
CONVERSATION.
IT'S NOT DISCIPLINING, THESE
ARE THE DISCIPLINE YEARS.
AS A CHILD EXPERT.
>> Tucker: IS THERE A POINT
WHERE THE BABY SAYS MOM,
STOP TALKING.
YOU TALK TOO MUCH.
GO AHEAD AND CHANGE THE
DIAPER.
I DON'T THINK MOST DADS
WOULD GO FOR THIS.
WHATEVER.
MAYBE DAD.
I DON'T KNOW.
HEY, PARENT.
STOP TALKING.
GO AHEAD AND CHANGE IT.
>> EXACTLY.
I DON'T THINK THESE ARE THE
YEARS THAT THE BABY WOULD BE
ABLE TO RESPOND BUT IT'S
JUST GETTING THE CONCEPT OF
I'M TOUCHING YOUR BODY.
YOU HAVE BODILY ATOM
YOU HAVE BODILY AATM
YOU HAVE BODILY AATOM MY.
YOU SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
SAY YES OR NO IF SOMEBODY IS
TOUCHING YOUR BODY.
I'M GOING TO TEACH THAT
CONCEPT DURING THE TRUST
YEARS.
>> Tucker: I LIKE THE
CONCEPT KIDS DO WHAT THEY'RE
TOLD.
THAT'S MY FAVORITE CONCEPT
FOR KIDS.